مؤلمه بعد 100 عام هذا هو مسلسل سفر اللي
كان مفاجاه الموسم الدرامي الرمضاني
الضخمه عن كارثه التهجير الجماعي القسري
اللي طبقتها الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
له قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهزيرها للمدينه حتى قيل في كثير من مصادر
التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص من
اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
العمل يروي حكايه السعودي عبد الرحمن
المداني ورفاق دراسه الجامعيه في اسطنبول
السوري يحيى واللبنانيين فايز وفريد حيث
يخوض الاصدقاء الاربعه رح الوعي السياسي
والانتقال من اروقه التحصيل العلمي الى
جبهات القتال مع الجيش العثماني اولا في
معارك البلقان على الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم
التمرد على ظلم السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه
ممارساتها
التفاصيل الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو
العربيات الحنطور التفاصيل التفاصيل
التفاصيل جدا كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه
بعنايه لدرجه انه فعليا الواحد فينا
بيصدقني اسطنبول كان كان شيء كثير كبير
لالنا
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان
كمان شيء كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كتير كان بالنسبه له ثلج كتير كبير وكتير
كان الجو حلو هنيك وما حسينا حالها يعني
انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات هون
كمان بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره لقلنا
انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى الجمهور والنقاد
تفاعلوا مع العمل باهتمام كبير هنا بعد
التغريدات
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل الدين بلاد انهم
يحاربون
لهم اولى في جهادهم ودمهم